foreign
[Music]
was founded in 1965 by Fred Deluca and
Peter Buck Fred DeLuca was then a 17
year old aspiring medical student and he
went to his family friend Peter Buck who
was a working nuclear physicist and
asked him for advice on how to pay for
college the two of them opened in 1965
the first location of Subway which was
then called Pete's super submarines
we've always known that Subway was a
cash cow Fred and Peter both debuted on
Forbes as billionaires rankings in 2004
with an estimated net worth of 1.5
billion dollars each but there's a lot
of questions about their wealth and we
think that potentially there's billions
of dollars that we didn't know about
over the years one clue to that was a
2017 deposition by Fred deluca's
personal banker which gave some rare
insight into their fortunes she claimed
that Fred DeLuca was pocketing about
seven million dollars in royalties each
week in the early 2000s and that wasn't
even at the peak of Subway's sales
Subway switched to a franchise model
about 10 years after the first Subway
sandwiches location opened and from
there it really experienced very quick
growth by 1988 they had 2 000 locations
across the U.S
Subway's Revenue peaked in 2012 at 18
billion dollars but has been on the
decline since 2015 which was the first
year that Subway closed more locations
than it opened
number one they began to read their
point of no return in the United States
that they had too many Subways on too
many street corners and the number of
stores just exceeded the demand number
two Subway had spent the prior 15 years
not developing new products and just
simply discounting their products and
every marketing professor and restaurant
professional will tell you that if
that's all you got you're you're
spinning your brand
both of the founding families of Subway
are very private and for a while after
they died Fred died in 2015 from
leukemia and then Peter Buck died at the
end of 2021 we didn't know what happened
to Subway but we recently learned what
happened to half of the fortune when the
foundation started by Peter Buck
announced that in his will he had left
instructions to give his half of Subway
to the foundation which then spends tens
of millions of dollars helping
charitable causes like in spanning
journalism land conservation efforts and
also closes in his local Danbury
Connecticut as for the other half owned
by Fred DeLuca the family has not
confirmed with us what happened to that
half of the company although there were
a lot of signs pointing to the fact that
it was inherited by his widow Elizabeth
DeLuca since his death Elizabeth DeLuca
has given hundreds of millions of
dollars to charity from herself so that
signals that the royalties that were
previously owned by Fred have been
redirected to Elizabeth
the DeLuca family through multiple
attempts did not respond to a request
for comment
foreign
so the announcement of the gift comes as
Subway confirmed that it is considering
options for sale The Wall Street Journal
reported that the price could be as much
as 10 billion dollars for Subway the
timing of this gift means that Peter
bucks as avoid a pretty hefty tax bill
if he didn't donate his half of the
company to the foundation then his
estate would owe 40 percent estate tax
on the fair market value of Subway upon
his death
in 2018 Peter Buck was engaged in a
legal battle with the IRS over his
gifting of some of his land that he had
accumulated in the North Main Woods to
his two sons Peter Buck started buying
Timberland in Maine in 2007 and during
his lifetime became one of the largest
landowners in the state with over 1.3
million Acres of Timberland so he gifted
some of that to his sons at a discount
from what he paid for it and then got
penalized by the IRS and he saved you
know millions of dollars on taxes by
doing that
it seems that the family still owns this
land his two sons likely own the land
which is valued anywhere from 300
million dollars to a billion dollars and
that doesn't appear to have been
included in the gift to the foundation
from Elia this year
[Music]
the buck family through their
representatives did not respond to a
request for comment
[Music]
thank you
Peter Buck was long charitable we
calculated that he had given away more
than 500 million dollars before his
death to his foundation as for Fred
DeLuca there was less charitable giving
before his death in 2015 but since his
death his widow Elizabeth has been
giving away money at a very fast rate
she's given away more than 400 million
dollars according to an analysis of
public documents and that doesn't
include gifts made in 2021 or 2022 as
the filings haven't been made available
yet
she's given more than 400 million
dollars to the Fred DeLuca Foundation
since his death in just a few years she
also Incorporated her own Foundation the
Elizabeth DeLuca foundation in 2020. I
spoke with one woman who runs a
non-profit that received a donation from
the DeLuca foundation in 2021 and she
described them as very purposeful in
their giving you actually can't apply
for a grant from them like you can from
many other foundations and instead they
come to you is what this person said and
they're known to have a big impact
targeting the people who need help the
most in some local communities in
Florida as for the bucks Peter Buck has
a lasting Legacy in Danbury Connecticut
where he spent the later years of his
life according to somebody I spoke with
he helped transform the city which is
has a population of about 90 000 people
and he was just very generous they're
both described to be very generous
people people
since you know 2015 and 2016 when
Subway's Revenue started declining and
the location started closing it's been
tough to run a Subway franchise
according to the franchisees in 2021 a
group of over 100 franchisees wrote a
letter to Elizabeth DeLuca outlining a
whole host of issues with the ownership
of Subway that they alleged was making
their jobs a nightmare in their own
words
[Music]
their average store revenues went up and
down like a ladder somewhere in the 400
to 500 000 range okay and that's very
hard to make any money on the other
sales sector
competitors Jersey Mike's Firehouse Subs
they are all running in the eight
hundred thousand dollar to a million
dollar range and that that hurts you
know because you can make money at eight
hundred thousand dollars or a million
dollars per shop sales but at 400 to 500
000 it's it's very difficult
Mr chizzy has noted in interviews that
what they want to do is they want to
consolidate out and kind of drive out
Force out the smaller franchises the the
Mom and Pops if you will this is not a
surprise they have been trying for the
last couple years to try to find bigger
franchisee operators to come in
and take over whole states of
franchisees the issue is that the the
store level profit has to be higher for
these bigger franchisee groups to be
interested in coming over and taking
over blocks of subway
and so the charitable donations have
some Subway franchisees kind of annoyed
I spoke with one who said that you know
the owners get to look good on the backs
of the subway franchisees who have been
struggling who have lost their
businesses in recent years and that
really those profits should be more in
their pockets than in the owner's
pockets that's something that has been
exacerbated as the sale nears
Subway responded to questions from
Forbes and said that it is improving its
relationship with its franchisees that
has made multiple steps to do so over
the past few years and that it needs a
good relationship with its franchisees
to thrive and is doing everything it can
to do that